why do you think men and women can't
seem to get together
it's all about right now currently
currently uh if I have to say based off
them stats you said
you got to realize that we was in a
pandemic so I think a lot of the
courthouses and a lot of things just
shut down I think that number might have
spiked in 2021 if we had those stats but
I think due to everything that was going
on that's where the dip happened a
pandemic what do you think the feminist
movement why because the feminist
movement encouraged women to be so
independent we don't need our men and if
you don't need a mandate you don't need
marriage so we we want or men to provide
but at the same time we want to be or
Independence so that created a
disconnect that affected the marriage
rate in my opinion and so you think it's
it's when do you think since like the
1920s like when or 1988 I believe was
when the feminist movie yeah like around
that time
um like around the 1970s 1980s okay when
um women started want the need to be
liberated okay okay what do you think I
think a lot of people don't want to get
married nowadays why I think they like
to be independent and have their own do
you think that's the men and the women
I think it's mostly women that want to
be independent yes and why do you think
that is
I think nowadays like women just want to
have like their own and don't really
want to depend on a man for anything so
almost like a backup plan okay yeah I
think there's too many distractions
nowadays I think people are in
relationships and don't want to fully
commit I don't know if it's because I
mean I've seen a lot with social media
people are distracted there's too many
options or they're always thinking okay
maybe there'll be a plan b or something
better will come along I think that I've
seen it a lot with um friends and I
guess even in my own personal cases do
you think that's the men the women or
both definitely both both yeah
oh so I'll start off with the term
because modern women are chaotic and
they want to live like holes
they want the power and the privilege
that Independence provides she said it
better than I did they don't want the
structure that masculine and bring so
it's easy to get attention from social
media and to give dates and to get what
you want on the outside without
obligations or responsibility so modern
women are the reason 98.2 I mean I give
you the research 98 responsible for the
decline in marriage today why do you say
98 we can't even give the men ten
percent
relationships if it if it succeeds or it
fails it's largely largely on women I
mean we'll do anything for the woman
they care about so that's why I say that
okay go ahead I blame it on the
feminists because they convince women
that they're equal to men and y'all are
not
and uh y'all feel like y'all don't need
us at all and you really do you know
World War III started today all that
[ __ ] would go out the window we could go
run into the friend zone
you'd be ready to be married
no more distractions
um so um a lot of so I'm gonna key in on
something you said
um that that women want to be
independent right do you think that
women should 100 depend on their men or
should they have a backup plan
I'll say 100 depend on your man
um that way when you feel like you want
to leave
you kind of can't nothing obviously not
in like you know a slavery way but yeah
um yeah you need to 100 depend on your
man okay what do you guys think I think
you should always have a backup plan
okay just in case it's almost like a
retirement plan here we go yeah I
completely disagree with you
um I any relationship I've ever been in
I always kind of put in the same work
work the same amount and it's always
been easier to split whenever you don't
rely completely on on your male partner
yeah the goal of a relationship is not
to split easily though
that's true but I don't think putting uh
being completely 100 dependent that
makes it seem like the females you know
just giving her all to the man and not
like
feeling any on her own yeah
that's the goal you think yeah so so
where's the woman why so he's a real
issue here like women should 100 trust
their men the reason why depending on
the man seems such a like a hard thing
is because you don't trust him and women
who don't trust their men have to depend
on them end up resenting them and that's
where you're going to see these with the
sneaky links on the side because he's
providing something that that man that
you depend on can't have so it's a real
the real issue here is not being able to
depend on him because most men you can
it's do you trust him are you willing to
mm-hmm
wives depend on their men
100 100 percent
do you think that you can have kids with
a guy and not depend on him
no no
so then how how would they always have a
backup plan if they're having kids with
a guy
I just mean when I think about it
financially maybe we'll put into that
perspective if a woman is not working
and depending on her relationship 100
and then if they decide to break then
what's she gonna do but you know having
kids I think it has to be uh
collaborative between the male the man
and the woman there's no way that just
one can I mean you can raise you know
somebody no offense to any single
mothers out there I think it's a great
thing to be able to do but
um to have both in the relationship is
so important yeah you know it's
interesting like why do we fear this
when women are the ones that leave
like men aren't leaving women leave 70
to 80 of the time and if they're call if
you're college educated you leave 90 of
the time
so it's interesting like it seems like
we as women have a fear of being left
but we're the ones leaving
that's because you don't never know what
you want
what yeah we don't usually
seriously
I think it's just a sense of confidence
isn't like you can handle it on your own
as well and like you don't necessarily
need that 100 provider like you
mentioned earlier in Brazil they know
what they want
do we think it's like something between
countries it's not feminism isn't as
heavy down there it's there though I
also think it's fair I'm sorry I think
it's fair why we want to have our backup
plan we want to have our own
um just in case he cheats or just in
case you know those movies told us that
men cheats so I'm just in case he cheats
let's not depend on him 100 but as Sir
Hill speaks if you trust your man then
do you think if a guy cheats on you it
should be over oh no no
wow what do you guys think
not at all no
go ahead a lot of women think that
cheating for a man means something it
means nothing a man can do what he does
and not know
he forgot about you right so for a man
it means nothing but if a woman does
that it she it meant something yeah
yeah
yeah
what what do you guys think if he cheats
is it are you leaving is it over
I think it depends on the circumstances
I will give somebody one chance but if
it's a repetitive thing absolutely not
and I don't know Sarah you said that a
man doesn't feel anything when they
cheat no not really
no emotional connection at all when it
comes to sexual intercourse nothing
after after he clinches that's it
that's it
do you agree from a male perspective do
you agree that the male doesn't have any
feeling yes yes I'm gonna say that that
100 agree with that there are times they
make and have sex with a woman and it's
like that posting that Clarity it's it's
it is what it is now in some rare cases
I do believe that it may be a special
woman it might be able to grab his
attention but she has to really be
exhibiting something that's just out of
the ordinary out of the norm yeah the
majority of women you just getting out
the way so no do you do you guys think
there's ever a line like that a girl
should leave like if it's like excessive
like if he's if he's screwing a new girl
every single night or if it's like what
I'm just curious from a guy's point of
view is there ever a line that a guy
could cross when it comes to cheating
where she should leave
I think she should be ashamed of herself
if that man feels so lonely oh my God
I go find something else I think that
woman needs to take a personal look at
himself and figure out why that man is
not being taken care of it's it goes
against our American values and I think
that one has to look at herself okay
okay what if what if he knocks another
girl up should she leave
[Music]
one of his siblings was like a
uh not like a love out of marriage child
that he knocked her up and he and he was
the youngest so his dad like stayed with
the white like they stayed together and
they had another kid
so what do you think should she leave
she should definitely I have a brother
liked it
it was somebody that my day I was
fooling around with for like 15 years
and I didn't know 15 years wow wow
actually like two or three of them so
did you have I mean if 15 years is a
long time do you think it was just sex
or did he actually no it was more than
six okay my mom had some problems that
that's why I couldn't understand why you
said she needs to take a look at herself
what I'm saying is that I think a lot of
men had separate families back in the
day
and nine times out of ten the woman
would know about it but she just played
a role she played a position so I think
it was more accepted back in the day
than it is right now but is that a bad
thing well this boy is 13. okay yeah
this is recent is that a bad thing that
it was more accepted back in the days I
mean family stayed together well I think
the in my opinion I think the focus was
more so on he was a good man he's a cat
household so as long as he did that then
there were some things that might have
been excused or may have been overlooked
it may not necessarily been the right
thing but the fact that he was a
provider for that house that was the
importance
one of you guys so what do you guys
think he knocks another girl up you
leaving you're leaving yeah yeah I'm
leaving I'm leaving 100 percent
yeah
that's what y'all say
um that's another it's a different story
when you uh you can pipe down that's a
different story but go ahead
um okay another question I have as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible